how's it going with my name welcome to I
guess the game will show you all right
yes
laughs it is an horror game it seems
pretty basic I think it was made for a
competition or I'm mixing it up with
something else it's the second one and I
only collect all [ __ ] is the nut lick
boner guys nice though this reminds me
of a haunted investigation
maybe it's inspired by it's the first
time I ever see anything of it I really
don't I'm a girl good thanks I always
wanted to scare my tits off I guess now
this is actually our yeah Brianna yep I
don't really like for is this but this
one seems kind of nice because it has
grass and there's one page that's click
on it always watches no eyes did
something happen
okay I'm waiting for someone
this is really creepy in my opinion the
thing about playing games he never paid
before you never know what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen
[ __ ] trees Kevin come on generate
view I don't like getting raped by trees
I happening crying man
this girl needs to work out what the
hell it's dude dude bro
let's try that again
I told ya [ __ ] new games they just
freak the freak her out of me all over
what
yeah I'm shaking like a [ __ ] right now
I am saying alright alright
it is not left what what did I do wrong
I don't get it I feel like a [ __ ] right
now I'm saying Oh me because I can't
make it three minutes video I just catch
alright blinking focus on the blinking
pity that is a tree that's how I guess I
don't care if you read me tree you can
do your worst
I would be a lot nicer then alright
can't run don't write the [ __ ] man that
is a house over there let's go to a
house there's someone there or what I
don't
dude I don't yeah i meanyeah skills i
want to lay on the floor and kill grass
with my can we ride the truck please
please please let you be rideable you
look so nice it's a Volvo isn't it
it's a [ __ ] Bolivar come here man
you're Swedish no they'd reject me
whatever I don't care it's their notes
on you what all right there you are
leave me alone are we good I think we're
good I think we are good let's try to
move faster here I don't want to run
into that man again it's okay though
I got two pages that's another car let's
go to the car got your Volvo the other
one rejected me I'll Trini you are
really bright too nice you are really
nice eyeball ah I don't even think your
Volvo with whatever what if my fashion I
wouldn't be here okay what do we have
here it's got to be on this Sun come on
why else would they put a [ __ ] car
huh you tricked me a Volvo I hope you
are happy I am sweating like a pig right
now I'm not gonna lie
let's continue then
calm down girl we're doing this together
he doesn't know we're here yet you know
anything when it's not a pipe I love
pipes I like them on Facebook I click
that here's a pipe it's pretty cold
can't be anything bad in there holy [ __ ]
what is that
cut the house coming up check out the
mud thing at a time pity Wow oh there's
a letter there I can totally sit he's
going to get it you need to work out
girl shake them hitters you have to clap
girl
what it's not to lose focus
he could be anywhere okay okay we're
good
I hope so
okay okay okay make the sad stuff house
my house in the middle of the penis
I do not expect this is what I usually
when I try against they're not really
that scary this is pretty [ __ ] scary
okay wait voice another it's gonna be
mr. share with the boy
[ __ ] that [ __ ] same let's get a big
nose here
I bet mister sharing your replica
oh my god oh my god we can do this tip
girl it's not a note it's gotta be note
in here it's barrels [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
I'm so close to stop playing this right
now I'm not kidding
Lisa share what the [ __ ] man hey that
looks good I know I am should be [ __ ]
anyway they keep me up oh oh no oh no oh
no I'm nice now it's [ __ ] please
[Laughter]
[Music]
or what the [ __ ] I'm telling you is when
I play games I do mascara and
yeah yeah and like oh that reminds me my
old cat
oh oh oh oh god they feel it I gotta
sleep Isaac yeah can't wait that make
nothing okay [ __ ] is going on